mesdames et mesdemoiselles billie
holiday
la mine aussi on vous aime
m a cp dit que billie holiday ella voix
de notre peuple on devrait intégrer
d'autres personnes dans le public ça
changerait la donne d'avoir des noirs et
des blancs associant semble
laquelle de mes chansons préférées vous
struyf roth ouais parle de chose
importante cette chanson de choses qui
se passent dans le pays
cette co leader mais de mauvaises idées
dans le g des gens et l'encouragent la
colère et les revendications du peuple
noir ces paroles sont provocatrice vous
avez un plan c'est une toxicomane
exactement
sa
cuisse
sortez-la de la scène death mais
il laisse plus chanter nulle part plus
de clubs pognon plus rien
tu es comme un marteau qui est revenu
pour frapper plus fort
elle a réussi à devenir quelqu'un vous
ne le supportez pas parce qu'elle est
forte belle et noir
soigner
rappelons lui
[Musique]
vous pensez que je vais renoncer à
chanter cette chanson aux petits enfants
chanteront foule